hi guys how are you hi hi
i feel like there's a comedy bit going
on that i should let happen
we hear laughter from between you
oh no no no that just laughing about
spilled water which is actually kind of
a comedy bit yeah it could be fun we'll
write it up
well i'm curious i mean when you guys
got the script and you read it and you
realized just what it was going to put
you through like what was your reaction
to that how did you feel about
everything you might have to endure to
make this movie
i thought the script was so laugh out
loud funny that it didn't totally land
with me that i would be the one doing
the stunts along with rob i thought this
is hilarious i can't wait to see this
without really understanding oh wait i
will have to do these stunts that are so
funny so it was sort of a wake-up call
um to the world of stunt work which was
a welcome call but yeah it was harder
than i thought it would be i a little
bit felt like it was like filling out
like a college application or something
because i knew the stunts were gonna
happen and i was like i hadn't yet said
yes so i remember like kind of doing
some thoughtful poses and being like i
think it's time it's going to be hard
but i think it's time is what i felt
like
i do remember reading the pool scene
when we volunte and absolutely believing
we would be outside in montreal in
february at night or that we would get
killed doing it perhaps all of the above
and thinking well this is how i'm going
to go yeah worse ways to get worse
how did the reality of the bull scene
compare because it is so great
we
genuinely got soaking wet
uh
we genuinely had to climb out of it
there were safety features in place to
prevent us from either drowning or being
asphyxiated by a wet plastic pool cover
um but
yeah i don't think
i never thought that that would be the
one where we'd be laughing the whole
time me neither i thought to be honest i
thought it would be like a labor of love
i thought it would be awful but glad
that we did it and it wasn't awful and
it was fun whereas a lot of the other
stunts were like we didn't necessarily
you wouldn't like get hurt but they
might be very physically uncomfortable
or repetitive whereas when they were
like okay we're gonna do it again i'd be
like oh goody yeah yeah i know i wish
we'd been able to do more do you
remember that was the shortest day we
did about two takes yeah we really
nailed it yeah we were very good at the
pool work for any
everything like gardening
everything these characters do in this
it centers around getting back a family
heirloom so what was it like to know
that they got put through all of this
and had to do all of this over what is
quite possibly the weirdest oddest
ugliest creepiest doll
big big kudos to the screenwriters mikey
day and streeter seidel for having the
sort of central you know mcguffin or
whatever in the film be that weird and
upsetting and ugly uh really want to
congratulate them for taking almost like
a sketch idea and being like what we're
a two hour film so i applaud them for
making the doll genuinely uh scary and
unsettling yeah oh when it's flying
through the air i mean that's the reason
i would say oh
little children just know this is
pretend
yeah it seems like one of those times
where you would be like no i don't want
to take the prop home just keep it away
from me i know you know the doll wait i
don't want the doll it's worth i don't
care it's too scary to look yeah yeah
i would imagine to you that having to
go through all of this torture with each
other sort of bonds you guys together as
actors
so what did you enjoy about working
together and having to rely on each
other through all of that did it also
help you find those comedy rhythms
definitely
yeah i mean i can't i'm not just boring
but i really can't say enough positive
stuff about ellie and to do like a
proper two-hander movie together where
we're always on screen together just
about most of the time and just feeling
like i had such a dependable partner was
really gratifying and made it easier to
do really funny stuff the more tender
stuff it just was
you were the best no same situation
right back at you because it was a thing
where i knew that rob was doing the
movie and i thought oh my gosh this is a
no-brainer for that reason and it was
it was a unique set of circumstances
also just as a real world check-in with
the pandemic going on and scary things
going on and it felt like oh what a
blessing a blessing what a what a gift
no blessing blessing
a blessing and a gift
to be able to work together through and
and like you said dependable um there
you know there were no there were no uh
surprises or antics it was just a it was
a nice steady experience steady is the
word steady experience
it was a steady experience very steady
as the writer of the original characters
john hughes is the one responsible for
creating this home alone franchise
so as actors what does the legacy of
john hughes and his movies mean to you
do you have a favorite john hughes movie
is there one that you've watched more
than all the others
honestly for me it might be home alone i
i i yeah isn't that an interesting um
maybe not expected pick but that's what
resonated with me at that time i think i
was maybe eight was i eight when it came
and i just watched it like over and over
again as soon as it was available to
rent
yeah for me it would be weird science
and ferris bueller's day off are the
ones that i've seen the most and uh in
terms of his ability to get
you know heart and humor and and danger
into into most of his scripts sort of an
equal measure
just
peerless yeah
it's like a magic trick i don't know how
you do that and yet he did it again and
again
and it still works i mean it still
inspires what is in this movie which i
think is kind of remarkable all this
timely
yeah
well i appreciate i fully appreciate you
guys talking about this your characters
are so much fun i love that we still
root for them even though they're sort
of
the people you're not supposed to be
rooting for but no you are
yeah but there's still so much fun i
totally sympathized with them
so thank you
thank you very much
you